an explosion at a market in armenia's
capital uravan has killed at least one
person more than 20 others were injured
the blast happened in a building at a
market where fireworks were being stored
everything shattered in a second there
are warehouses technical rooms it's like
fireworks fireworks fireworks everything
happened in one minute people could not
get out of the stores
we can now speak with maria titusyan
who's a journalist she's based in
yerevan welcome to al jazeera
what more are you learning about the
cause of that blast
um at the moment um
we do know that as you said there's one
dead 34 injured
about 10 of them children they've been
treated and released there's only one
child currently in hospital with
non-life-threatening
injuries at the moment we don't know
exactly
there has been no official announcement
that about the exact cause we know that
there was a fireworks depot right beside
the surmalu market and um just up until
about 15-20 minutes ago fireworks were
still going off um the smoke is still
blazing they're trying to douse it but
at the moment we
don't have any official uh information
as to the exact cause
the minister of emergency situations is
on the ground as uh our dozens and
dozens of fire trucks at the moment tell
us about the building itself and
presumably that market would have been
busy on a sunday
yeah absolutely it is a very busy market
we do know that
a three-story building three walls have
collapsed and now the the main building
itself uh is in danger of completely
collapsing um we don't have any
information if anybody has been pulled
out of the rubble at the moment or how
many people are actually trapped
but as that you could see from the
images there was tremendous smoke and
dust people just running for cover as
other smaller buildings uh around the
the main market were also um
collapsing
yeah we can see the live picture right
now where smoke is still belowing in
fact from from that building um maria
tetsuya what has been the reaction of
people that you have been speaking to
well it's been utter shock this is the
first time in in my memory that such an
explosion such a tragedy has happened in
the capital city
um
everybody is glued uh to social uh media
networks and to the news to try and find
out what's happening um
and absolutely it's uh
you know summer in yerevan lots of
tourists i don't think many tourists
would have been in the particular market
uh but of course just from my balcony
you could see uh the the smoke um there
are people who are saying that in the
city center you could smell plastic and
the smell of smoke we're i'm a little
bit higher up uh from the city center
so yeah it's very disconcerting uh and
and very worrying obviously all right
we'll leave it there thank you so much
for giving us that update from yerevan
thank you